this video is sponsored by babble hey
there guys so this video is going to be
a bit different from my usual videos I'm
doing a bit less editing I'm going to
slow it down and just chat with you
about my current training because my
training recently has gone through some
changes I've made some big alterations
to the exercise selection and the way
I'm designing my splits and I've seen
some improvements in some areas as a
result and I thought I'd share it with
you guys a lot of people ask me how I
train what the exact workouts I do look
like so I thought it could be
interesting to talk about that here at
the same time it's hopefully going to
serve as a bit of an update because at
the start of the year I talked about my
goals for the year and what I wanted to
achieve I was going to be changing my
training and just before that I made a
video on how I'd been struggling a
little bit with burnout so yeah I
thought I'd just update you guys and let
you know how it's been going and what my
plans are going forwards as well because
on the whole it's been going really well
I've seen some great breakthroughs in
terms of my training so I thought I'd
share it with you here at the same time
talking about some of the pitfalls I
faced and how I'm planning on overcoming
them because with training it's very
often about taking those two steps
forwards and one step backwards so yeah
first I'll talk about the biggest change
to my training and that's been that I've
switched to a full body routine I was
doing a kind of push-pull leg split I
actually did push pull legs full body
this is the same that I talk about in
the super functional training 2.0
program I've always really liked
push-pull legs because it allows you to
really get some intensity on each
movement pattern and that way you can
grow and see results faster but I also
find that that kind of training is a bit
less flexible and so for where I am
personally right now in my life full
body makes a bit more sense and this is
something to think about it's not a
question of which is better it's a
question of which is better for you
which is better for your current goals
so the reason that full body is working
a bit better for me at the moment is
because a I've switched a bit more to
skills type work as I talked about in my
goals video I'm focusing a lot more now
on hand balancing and on planche and
calisthenics skills just as something
fun to work on because I love that stuff
and so for that being able to train
regularly and practice these moves and
grease the groove makes a lot of sense
and that's why switching to a full body
routine makes a lot of sense a lot of
the benefits of a push-pull bag eggs
routine come from the fact that you are
able to go much harder train much more
intensively with more volume as well and
that then is going to need more recovery
so yeah for skills makes more sense to
do full body at the same time when life
is really unpredictable and I talked
about this in my last video on training
for parents when you just don't know if
and when you're going to be able to fit
your next training routine in it does
make sense to switch to full body
because if you skip a day of full body
you can just do that same workout the
next day if you've got a more complex
split whether it's push-pull legs or
whether it's something else a bro split
then it gets much more complicated you
miss a day and now suddenly it's been
ages since you trained your legs now
suddenly got to move this around and
train this and it just gets a lot more
difficult to fit in so yeah for me at
the moment full body makes more sense
and it means I'm hitting each muscle
group more often which I have found for
me is good for growth now I'm going to
take a moment to talk about today's
sponsor Babel so Babel is one of the top
language learning apps in the world that
uses intuitive lessons designed by real
language teachers allowing you to fit
language learning in around your day and
your schedule for me language learning
is just a bit of side hobby something
that I like to dabbling every now and
then Babble allows me to do this by
letting me fit 10 minute learning
sessions in wherever I am so I dabble
with Babel two languages I've been
trying to learn are German and polish
because I'm half polish and a quarter
German and I'm ashamed to say that I've
never been able to speak either of those
languages despite enjoying their
Cuisines quite a lot fun fact I once
lied in a job interview at IBM and told
the interviewer that I knew how to speak
German and then he started speaking to
me in German and it was really awkward
I've been having the most luck with the
German this time that schnitzel is Dem
Tish means the Schnitzel is on the table
ikaba schnitzel I have eaten the
Schnitzel if you would like to be able
to tell people what you've eaten in a
range of different languages then why
not give Babel a try if you click the
link below then you'll get 60 off of
your subscription let me know in the
comments down below Which languages you
chose to learn and why at the same time
I've made this modular and I've talked a
lot about modular training lately the
way I approach this is basically to
split each part of my workout into
little section one section might be for
legs one section might be for a body but
one section might be Mobility or skills
work and then what I can do is if I
don't have time to train everything I
take a module and I do that on another
day some modules I'm going to do more
often like Mobility work I might do five
days a week whereas you know max
strength training might do three days a
week I am still doing all that other
stuff by the way I'm still training you
know in a very cross-functional manner
I'm still doing a lot of kettlebells
still doing some heavy lifts still doing
a lot of cardio it's just that I've got
more focus on calisthenics so I'm doing
all that other stuff and a way to fit
that in for me who's very busy as a
parent running this channel taking lots
of holidays lately it's just good to
have that flexibility to say I didn't
manage to do all this right now I'm
gonna do this later so essentially by
designing my training plan in a modular
way I can either combine everything and
do a full body workout or I can snap
bits off and do them sporadically
throughout the day or I can break the
whole workout in half and do two short
ones instead and this gives me loads of
flexibility and today I've gone here and
I'm gonna do some hanging cobra
stretches for my back so yeah that's
kind of how I mix it up and split it
throughout the day this one comes
courtesy oh SFA keys
by the way I did recently share my full
body routine over on patreon all tears
get access so you just have to donate
one dollar a month and you can always
unsubscribe the next month if you want
to check it out I'll leave a link to
that in description down below so if you
want to follow my exact training program
and also see how it changes over time
because it'll be updated live then you
can go and check out the link in
description down below but this video
isn't really about the precise training
program it's more just about how my
training has changed why it's changed
and also what I'm seeing as the results
from that at the same time if you
watched my video my goals of the year
you know I made this Ironclad rule that
was always going to show up for the
training no matter what even if it just
meant doing five minutes I have stuck
with that that has been the ethos but I
have also you know adapted it slightly
to be more nuanced because I was kind of
implying that I'd go to the gym and do a
workout every day or work out from home
at the very least and whilst I am doing
that I do something every day but that
might just be stretches and I've put
more emphasis on this because what I've
realized lately is that I have been
overdoing it I've been struggling with
burnout I keep getting sick because my
daughter's bringing these illnesses home
from preschool but at the same time I'm
hardly sleeping I'm cramming in way too
much work taking on too many
responsibilities and as I talked about
in that video and I have mentioned
before coming up with a good training
program and a good plan for getting into
shape isn't just about looking at the
exercises you want to do in a vacuum
you've got to think about the broader
context of your lifestyle not only how
you're going to fit in your training and
your commuting and your washing but also
do you have the energy because when
things get tougher you need to scale
back your training that's just common
sense I realized that training five
times a week six times a week seven
times a week in a more intense way was
starting to be to my detriment so whilst
I'm still active every day because I
highly believe that's important and the
more I stick to that the better I am by
the way the more active I am the more I
move throughout the day the better my
back's been the better my energy has
been but at the same time I don't want
to keep overdoing it so I do three big
intensive workouts a week just three and
I did talk in that video as well about
how I was planning on scaling back my
commitments Outsourcing a bit more work
taking on for your sponsors Etc that
also hasn't really gone to plan to be
honest and I'm also the same in every
area of life where I'll you know book
holidays with people say it's okay I'll
fit working around it or I'll do
something else and just pile it on and
on and yeah I haven't been great at
easing up on that that's on me and that
is something I need to work on but
unfortunately it's also just my
personality so it is tricky for me to
find ways around this as for the back
like I say I decided eventually to go
and see a chiropractor and that was
actually quite hard for me because you
know being the bioneer and a functional
coach you feel like you should be able
to fix these things on your own like you
shouldn't need outside help but the
truth is that when you're too close to
the situation it's really hard to judge
yourself not only is it hard to see
yourself unless you're filming yourself
and playing it back which I do do at the
same time you know you think you're
better than you are and that was
actually a lot of my issue I'd be
jumping ahead so a lot of the exercises
that were recommended to me with things
like dead bug here's me doing Dragon
flag and attempting front levers with
ice cream makers and things like that I
think it's going really well it's been
months since I have any issue and I'm
just going to really maintain that I'm
going to just focus on it more because
it's clearly a weak point for me I just
need to focus on it more not ignore it
because it's boring and I want to do
other stuff but always prioritize
strengthening the back improving
mobility in that area and yeah I'm
hopeful that it won't be an issue
anymore so yeah it's actually made a big
difference and this also helped me to
focus a lot more on my Mobility which is
also backing up the calisthenics
training next you'll notice anyone who's
big into calisthenics skills there's a
lot of Mobility because you can't do a
handstand if you can't get your hands
over your shoulders yeah my shoulders
has been the big sticking point I've
seen some great Mobility gains in my
hamstrings in my straddle in my back
particularly thoracic rotation which has
all been great and I feel looser and
more energetic but at the same time my
shoulders are really really stubborn and
they just don't want to open up so yeah
I'm doing more work on that what I'm
really happy with is that the handstands
have improved in particular I can now do
maybe two handstand push-ups pretty
reliably I'll fall over some of the time
but not all the time whereas before it
was like a once in a blue moon thing I'd
actually pull it off so yeah I'm pretty
happy with that that's come along
quickly and nicely the plant training
hasn't been as successful but I'm
stepping back from that and doing a
little bit more l-sit and v-sit and I
have noticed now that I can get my legs
up higher and I can hold it for longer
so that's really good and I'm hoping
that some of these straight arm strength
from that is going to transfer over once
I get back to focusing more on the
advanced Tucker planche and straddle
planche
so calisthenics has very much been the
main focus of my training lately though
I'm still doing a lot of the other stuff
like kettlebells and cardio Etc that
said I've almost entirely dropped
isolation work in a more bodybuilding
style for things like my biceps and
triceps and I was a bit concerned about
doing this because I thought I'd lose
some size and definition and although
that's never been a main focus for me I
would say in my goals video that I did
want to if anything improve the
Aesthetics a little bit because I see a
tangible and direct result when it comes
to click-throughs on the channel maybe
that's not ideal but that's the way it
is but actually if anything changing to
this style of training has improved
things slightly also scaling back my
training a bit I thought that that might
be a downside but again if anything it's
improved things part I think this is
because of my training background where
I do a lot of you know extremely high
rep continuous time under tension pump
style training I think that actually has
given my body the ability to deliver
blood nutrients to the muscles and to
cope with recovery a lot better so I
think that's still really useful and
maybe I'm just in the right point in my
life to switch to this style of training
and at the same time as that by using a
full body routine and then using
additional stuff on top of that
throughout the week I'm actually hitting
each muscle group very frequently and
this is really good for spiking protein
synthesis regularly I think my body
really likes that and at the same time A
change is always good if you hit a
plateau of any sort happening since my
shoulders improved with a lot more focus
on things like Pike push-ups military
press and handstand training so that's
really good because I did say that was
something I wanted that's an area that's
been lacking so for me at the moment I'm
feeling great about my progress because
you know I've got more balance and
strength in hand balancing which is what
I really wanted because it just opens up
so many other cool things and I can go
from a handstand into a bent arm planche
now which is fun and I like doing that
going forwards I want to start adding
more weighted calisthenics in because
really in terms of like my pull-ups and
my dips I'm at the point where I'm doing
really high rep ranges and it's not
necessarily that conducive to strength
building or skills training anymore the
only problem is I find it real fast to
put on weights to do the weighted
calisthenics and I'm all about that
efficiency game in and out and doing the
work so I need to look into a way to do
that properly and yeah I need to find a
way to scale back the amount of work I'm
taking on a little bit so that I have
more energy for training and to make
better quality stuff God actually made a
video recently talking about
perfectionism on his channel and how
he'd intentionally scaled things back
for that particular video at least in
order to not only you know create videos
and actually get content out and stop
worrying about it and stressing about it
but also to make something that's more
authentic so yeah maybe I need to focus
a little bit less on you know going to
the woods and flying my drone around and
you know doing all these crazy things
dressing a kettlebell up like a baby and
Swinging it in the park and throwing ice
into the trolley and bringing my camera
into Tesco and just actually you know
make content when I talk to you guys
what do you guys think is that something
that you'd like to see or do you
appreciate the visuals that go along
with the Audio I know personally I tend
to just listen to YouTube whilst I'm in
the kitchen cooking so I don't even tend
to look at what's on the screen anyways
maybe you guys are the same
so far to be honest and look at the main
lessons that I've learned from switching
my training program up lately a lot of
it basically revolves around listening
to my body dropping the ego slowing
things down scaling back and honing in
on my focus and by doing those things
ironically I've actually moved forwards
at a greater Pace I've been more
consistent so so yeah it's a case of
slow and steady wins the race and I
guess adapting to your situation and by
training maybe slightly less listening
to my body more getting external help
where necessary and slowing things down
a little bit yeah I've busted through
some plateaus and it's going really well
so I think that's the take home message
I'd love to know in the comments down
below how your training is going what
are you guys working on right now what
have been your setbacks what kind of
program are you following if you want to
talk about this more deeply then the
higher tier patreon members not only get
access to a exclusive Facebook group but
now also get access to an exclusive
Discord server just set that up I'm
hoping it'll be a great place to chat
and I'll be stopping by from time to
time to engage with the chat again the
patreon link is in the description down
below either way guys thank you so much
for watching this video and I'll catch
you next time
bye for now